hey so we I guess didn't you see
actually a couple of weeks ago we saw
early screening yeah train to Dragon
three but you had to go on vacations
later and I've forgotten everything
well no buts coming out this week so I
miss out works out okay so now I have to
see it again uh I want to see this again
this is oh really yeah oh I enjoyed it I
didn't realize you were in the camp of
like no I really want to see this again
no no okay when we saw we saw it on a
normal screen no 3d no IMAX and the
greatest 3d movie I've ever seen is How
to Train Your Dragon I saw it on IMAX
and so on 3d is the best 3d experience I
ever had so and we saw two in 3d but it
but it wasn't IMAX and that really does
make a difference so if they released
this on IMAX which they might not
because of battle angel it's like damn
it but but if you can see it in 3d I
haven't seen this one 3d I'm assuming
it's gonna be great because the era two
were great you can see that IMAX
definitely do that so yeah this is the
third film and give you a background
what we thought of the other two I like
the first one a lot I didn't even though
it's like a run-of-the-mill story it's
done so well the first one was one of
the biggest animated film surprises I
can remember yeah next I like kung fu
got on a whim as my wife was pissed off
cuz her university team lost and he's
like we should go I see movement now
there was like nothing showing and I'm
like well you look like you need
cheering up let's just watch this
animated movie night seen the trailers
in the trailers look it didn't look like
much it's terrible and came out of that
film and we both looked at him like why
was that so good and why was that one of
the best 3d movies I've ever seen and
then the second one came out also really
good it changed it up a little bit it
still had beautiful animation but it's
one of those when I think back I'm like
yeah I remember a couple of things that
happened some of the visuals but here to
tell me in order what happened I
probably couldn't but it's like I still
remember it being really good the
characters are charming and
ya know that's the biggest part and just
this guy who looks like the penguin
doing God like a really weak lame
villain I wasn't a huge fan of the
villain that yeah that's where the big
problem with it but everything else is
pretty good in that they were both good
yeah and so we feel like the first two
and now we have this third one which I'd
be shocked if they make another one
after this
they better not I don't know if I got a
Toy Story for it but I'm already pissed
off about Toy Story with it doing it
like this is the file they do overturn
the king and credit sequence yes I
remember this moment member this moment
so it really feels like I know by the
way the trailers for Toy Story 4 before
this movie that we saw are not giving me
any confidence it looks awful that what
most Pixar trailers look really really
bad don't fix our trailers are bad so
there's that but ok would be my general
thought is that they this is a this is a
good movie of good ending the enemies at
the ending ending the most ever yeah
well I mean as a film like it's a good
you know yeah I'm in the ending to this
movie really I knew they knew right
where to end it like it just I'm like
God that felt so perfect like so so so
so here's the thing so this movie it's a
it's a well done movie it's one of those
you ever watch a film and they're like
oh yeah that's kind of weird that that
happened but okay whatever it's like a
nip acute and of look past it this one I
found looking back there it's like yeah
they're just nip --ax but there are a
lot of them and they do kinda get in the
way for me for say like yeah this was
really like a great finishing film I
can't say like it's great but it has
really great things in it and as a thing
compiled together it's like this is good
and like it's a lot see it again
especially in 3d but I feel like seeing
it again I'm gonna notice the the odd
little things that kind of stood out
about did you have the same reaction cuz
never talked about it them there were a
lot of odd little things the comedies
hit-and-miss mmm-hmm
I the the villains kind of hit and miss
where I'm just like I
the character design is strange I
honestly thought how to talk to hell you
mean honestly thought for a second that
he was gonna be voiced by Christopher
Walken because he looks like if you
stretched his face if you took
Christopher Walken and Brad was talking
about this to combine him with judge
Frollo from Hunchback of Notre Dame and
yeah mix him with a touch of Count
Chocula and like the ending of
ratatouille or I was gonna say and the
bad guy from Doctor Strange I forget
that actor yeah and then squish them all
together and you get like this guy so
what's so funny though is he is
technically the it might be in the best
villain we've had cuz he is no charming
and he's kind of cool and he sleek very
well put together
if you were to say like what's you know
what motivates him to do what he does
it's like I can tell you but it's kind
of dumb yeah we didn't get much in the
way of the story with him a lot of these
they're very Marvel movies in the sunset
that's always the Achilles heels of
these three films has been the villains
are not particularly strong ones a lot
of the motivation it's like it's there
but it's not great like the romance in
this you know but between hiccup in the
what's her name I can't remember the
girl's name but you see it develop over
the films and then here it's like okay
they're kind of together but they don't
really there's one scene where they're
kind of fake you know wrestling teehee
haha and then that's kind of it like the
connection between him and his mother I
was saying his dead father actually does
more parenting in this than the living
mother okay I'll disagree with the first
part I thought the romance was fine okay
I thought they were adorable together
um the mother is a great but I was
talking to my wife about this I'm like
it's really clear that they wrote this
mother character in movie two killed the
father and then suddenly realized in
movie three we know what to do with this
yeah like because they set this up as
this badass character and then they they
must have realized instinctually like we
have to have hiccups wife she's got to
be badass she's like you know so I feel
like they
boosted her character and brought down
the mother character so that it which is
fine but it definitely a character yeah
it definitely you can tell where it's
just like man they didn't know where to
go with that kid they wrote themselves
into a corner and like crap because we
really should make it about these two
getting married that which I'm fine with
because I feel like that's been
developing over time I'm like yeah no if
you're gonna sacrifice something it
needs to be that we've had parenting in
the first two movies like we don't need
it a third time if you got to sacrifice
something I'm okay with them sacrificing
that it is weird
the the tentacles of the story about why
they do some things again it's not like
all four super distracting but it's like
just enough like they're gonna this bad
guys got this bad guy comes in with like
a couple dangerous dragon I even like
big ones they're dangerous ones but they
literally have an island of dragons and
like we got to get out of here because
this guy he's really sleek he's really
dangerous he's not gonna stand so they
just move like the whole island of
people away and I'm like well that's a
little odd and the motivation is that
this other army just kind of wants to
take down the dragons or they want to
own land they're not developed very well
we just know there's a time and it's
really bitch biggest firm world the
world building step back
yeah particularly where the villains are
concerned cuz I'm just always like it
but if you have all these dragons why
can't you defend this defend yourself
it's like ah well they got better
dragons and like I'm like what what are
these peoples is it just because they're
freeing the dragons then why take them
out which technically if you want to get
really technical that's always kind of
thing like in the first no to with like
the alpha dragon stuff which is also
can't confusing and it's even more
confusing here honestly because then
there's this thing about toothless
people that alpha of this group but now
is the Alpha of all dragon I I always I
always like that concept you guys like
but he can't get a mate we have to save
alpha and all the other dragons by
killing this really big dress yeah it
kind of gets even more confusing like
this weird like animal like save the
animals message in the first movie and
yet I'm just like but you have to kill
an animal that like this is yeah there's
more than that and it leads to a climax
but it's again not at all a bad climax
but it's I mean they're building um you
see
this army that's like five return of the
king armies on the sea and they're all
coming and stuff and it's actually a
very tiny small-scale climate here to
what it could have been so grateful so
many Marvel movies so many animated
films and they did these climaxes just
get bigger and bigger and I like that it
had this like Wrath of Khan thing where
it's just like dragons one villain one
guy but but why not make it look like
this is what you're gonna get why build
up one thing unless you're gonna do
something it was basically happening in
the background it just focused more on
hiccup in the villain I didn't even
notice I thought was mostly just unlike
this one dock or Harbor or whatever
would this one ship and like so there is
they're freeing dragons I did I don't
know that just didn't bother me I liked
the Loki like um cuz I'm just it's just
I'm coming to a point with a lot of
these movies where these climaxes are so
huge they're getting very se me so I'm
just like you know what two dragons and
one of them like keeps getting possessed
and some I was enjoying watching those
to fight it out versus just like a giant
stock CGI battle not now here's what I
was gonna ask because I noticed this
early on especially because we saw the
lego movie - after this lego movie - is
very fast it's just like the first one
where the action is super quick and they
throw a lot at you this one it almost
seemed like it's impressive because they
try to shoot it in one shot and it's
definitely well put together but it
seems slower compared to other animated
films and what I'm wondering is if you
got the same idea I did did they slow it
down to make it feel like well these are
characters with actual weight and when
they jump you want to feel like they're
actually jump absolutely which is why I
liked the zoom I think more than like
I've been watching some of the other
reviewers and they're like I was just
like I felt way more invested in this
movie and the way they were trying to
grow these characters I didn't it was
very hiccup centric in the second one
and as Danny's mom comes in but I was
getting sick of just like his band of
idiots that he surrounds himself with
that just only seemed to get into
trouble hmm I felt they were with the
with the exception of one who gives away
their location she's an idiot I I
thought they were at least
may still be kind of goofy but they were
more useful in this like yeah your
little idiots but they do you're all
doing in this third film and they
were like scenes where people just talk
and like this like this exposition scene
where he's like drawing in the sand and
he's like I'm trying to figure out what
to do and I don't know what to do and
like I've got a rule that I'm just like
I can't believe it because I mean I've
always complained about the voice pickup
which I always get used to every time so
in the end I'm fine but I'm like Frank I
enhance this kind of voice like this
third film in particular I'm like wow I
can't believe it I really feel like this
guy's grown as a character I feel like
most um have grown as a character that
we moved from point A to point B to
Point C except in the humours always
been a little more cause like when it's
miss here its weirdness so a lot like
some hits are good like I like when they
have they have this prisoner that won't
shut up and you can tell it was just
improv like she's making up but I
thought that was pretty funny but then
there's like a weird running joke we're
like one of the kids I guess are not
kids anymore but but like one of the
younger guys has like the hots I think
for hiccups mom like is that what they
were doing I think yeah at first I
thought oh she must be this high
authority like he's trying to suck up to
her but then it's like oh I guess like
he has the hots for her but it's like
for something supposed to be really
funny you could have developed that and
just Dora made it funny I just don't
care yes because it's like if my biggest
problem is a few jokes don't land but
the rest of the movie like takes itself
kind of seriously and grows the
characters in a way that yeah and that's
why this does work I don't see like I'm
gonna get for this okay like I like
the Toy Story trilogy a lot they do
develop the characters
I don't feel they're really insanely
developed though I feel like yeah you're
still Buzz Lightyear you're still I
don't feel much of a sense of
progression except for accepting the
fatalistic you know end that eventually
Andy's not gonna want to play with you
like well that's always what is you have
to accept this
the inclusion that's what every movie
the characters don't evolve that much to
me first movie did woody in Toy Story 3
is still woody in Toy Story this one I
do not recognize this hiccup from movie
one hmm I just don't and I was just
watching movie one again the other day
and I'm just like they actually
developed this characters and most of
the characters in it like a couple of Oz
idiot sidekicks maybe that's most of
characters in it have actually really
developed and I'm just like if you told
me that the one solid trilogy of
animated films outside of Toy Story that
was going to have a complete story arc
that develops its characters beginning
to end and it's pretty convincing is How
to Train Your Dragon I would also argue
no DreamWorks I would argue Panda the
only the only thing about Kung Fu Panda
is III the second ones my favorite and I
love the first one a lot I do not hate
the third one at all don't like don't
not like a big leap like no it's just I
kind of just forget about hmm it's I
don't want to say it's the Iron Man too
because that movies legit bad but there
is kind of a quality of just like yeah
that happened and I don't really
remember anything about it like I
remember how to train your dragon all
three of them or then Kung Fu Panda
where I remember the first two really
really well I'm Erin when there's a
better one and there's one I'm like
that's good that's alright
when a development happens it feels like
oh wow the character in movie three
would have done something very different
than the one in movie one yeah there's
been a real complete story arc here and
I'm like where do you see that an
animated film source is it's rare that
you get like three in a row but it's
just like even in the DreamWorks like
you got like your Shrek's and stuff
which kind of feel like one offs like I
will develop a little but it's still ya
know where there actually is a contained
like they JIT Emilio up yeah and I
thought that like for as much as some of
the humor doesn't land I thought it was
such a great accomplishment that I take
this kid seriously even with that voice
I'm like no he's trying his best to
actually save his people and like put
something together and he's got a memory
listen to what people are instead of
yeah he's got a great group with his
quote unquote future wife and fee
I'd say or whatever and is his mother
and then the other villagers and it I
don't know I was like I was way more
wrapped into it than I ever thought I
was gonna be I was like wow you really
won you would went all-in what my
favorite tried to tell an actual
complete story and wrap it up my
favorite bit that shows kind of both
evolving still learning lessons but also
being funny and easy as in the trailer a
toothless comes across this this other
night Night Fury not Night Fury yeah I'm
like fury this one's a light fear yes
and we're gonna call it a white fury but
that probably a white fury but it just
sounds like some group so they have so
so either hiccups trying to help them
you know get along with this light fury
and I'm glad it isn't just the whole
film is nothing for trying to impress
her and he screws up like legit bro but
you see like he's gonna be off pants
again about him let it go and hiccup
turns into this very paranoid parent
about two things just like my dresser I
don't I mean well why isn't he back yet
I told me back by assignment Issa and
that's something that's
heartbreaker yoko ono bitch comes over
and is trying to steal my bro that's
really funny
yeah it shows him still learning which a
lying is not like he has everything
figured out and you see him come to a
conclusion with that as well so it's a
character that not only has he fault but
he's still evolving and is doing it in a
funny this has been an actual theme
throughout the whole series which is
anything where the series has consistent
themes which I think all three of them
in a way are about letting go first
one's about letting go if your
prejudices your your hatred like
embracing new ideas second one he loses
his father you know and this one it's
about letting go of toothless and along
with leaving your home it I know I was
really surprised and I think my favorite
thing and it's been my favorite thing in
all of them is that damn dragon yeah it
is it's like if you crossed a
cat with a lizard with a puppy and the
bat and they they all work flawlessly
together they've actually and then I get
cat probably can't but but it's
definitely more bouncier there's a puppy
like aspect to it too they combined it
so flawlessly it is its own thing though
you see a little bit of everything it's
a little bit of candle but a puppy a
little bit of bat little and like that
was my favorite scenes is when he was
trying to impress the other the the
light fury and like the the stupid
sounds he would make and the way they
were like doing this weird mating ritual
flirting damn yeah I I thought it was
adorable and I thought they the
animators God I'll credit to them they
have a real keen sense of animal
movements and instincts coming up that
the backgrounds in this half the time
I'm like I'm just looking at a real
background even though walking I'm like
I'm looking at real people until they
turn around and you see they have
cartoony faces they like the textures
because they just look totally Rigas
thing and this is gonna sound insane but
this is her animation geeks so in every
one of these CGI yeah whenever every one
of these CGI movies there's always
something new that they tend to tackle I
I know fur was really big for Monsters
Inc the the hair was really big and in
brave of the lighting and underwater
effects finding Dory and stuff I don't
know why in this one
Sam Sam looks amazing in this just like
did they just really shoot that on the
beach I'm like no that's particle
effects that I'm like they're getting
good like the sand of red line in the
sand you do know I and it's such a small
thing to notice but I just turning to
you and I'm like that just looks amazing
I know it's just sand but and it's
always a little things like people who
are through Mars and it gets over yeah I
hate sand
let's hate it you're like water but yeah
so all credit to the animators just for
the sand but also just the way they draw
these dragons the the night and light
fairy in particularly the others have a
goofy quality there
to look goofy there the side characters
but those two dragons in particular the
animators just outdid themselves and
this one I think in particular with
looking and feeling like real animals I
honestly thought I'm like if these
things exist of course this is how they
would act it just felt real they moved
it that the sound design that the sounds
on them oh it is a little bouncing yeah
but the whole worry I'm so impressed for
stories that are so like you said just
see pass prejudice and it's kind of like
a liar reveal story in the first one
then just an hour ago I mean these are
such stock stories but the way they're
died it's the same people who did lilo
and Stitch it's the same thing that's
such a stock story but the way it's done
and the world it creates and these
characters it creates I mean it just
really feels like kind of a real play
like this place could exist even though
it looks very cartoony and very goofy
and in this one like they look more and
more realistic and what you know I guess
as the film's grew up the style kind of
grows up to it gets more I didn't you're
looking realized watching it that I was
gonna get something more like Lord of
the Rings where you feel like everybody
has a character are can you watched one
complete whole set yeah I thought when
they were gonna do sequels I'm like
whenever it's gonna be another one oh
off and you know it's not going to
really advance the story much they're
just gonna do it for a cash grab and
they didn't and I'm super impressed by
it it is the reason why some of the the
humor and some of the world-building
that making a ton of sense is
problematic I don't like that because I
used to build in each one this way I can
takes a step back but the stuff that
they really do well you say a lot of
carriages do come a long way it does
feel like a legit ending and the
characters are still learning things
while they still remember the things
they've learned before they don't
regress or differ as I say that what's
progressed but what Devo Devo
yeah I'll say that much Burwood Oh evil
but you know it when I see grass okay so
okay but when we get to when we get to
the end because like I said I saw the
the climax of this I'm like oh well it's
kind of hoping for a little bit more of
emotional powerhouse but the emotional
powerhouse is right after the climb ass
and it is so well done and
particularly the emotional powerhouse
scenes have nothing to do with the
action in this movie yeah that's the
interesting thing and I think that's why
I like it more than some people because
I'm just so a lot of to like it we've
gone into such an epic moviemaking mode
where it's like we have to have the big
action scene and the big action scene
will mean something and it's all about
poses in this net and and the one-liners
and stuff every weighty moment in this
film is way softer and quieter and I'm
like I see that much that there's no in
the climax where I'm like that that
match perfectly and again without giving
too much away it's with the character
falling and I thought the way they tied
in and not just the action but also what
we know about the characters and what
they're learning evolving and stuff in
the way that came to resolution a lot
like that was really solid and kind of
from there on the movie is kind of
flawless and that it knows now what to
give you what what you're gonna deliver
how to wrap this up and I feel there's
one scene in particular I just thought
when I saw it again I'm like a fighting
man tears like this was really tough guy
I won't give it away but it's a scene
with a hand and it's a it's something
similar to what happens in the first
movie and I thought that was so freakin
brilliant and it's such a good callback
that I said okay this really feels like
we've been on like this big journey and
even though it hasn't been like graphic
you know there's things that you know
exam is it the misses are not major in
my opinion now that their little misses
and when I may add up but man you just
feel like you been through a really big
journey this is the thing that people
don't understand I think people thump on
critics too much or when they disagree
can't you just enjoy the movie wait did
I put that things you don't like I have
always said if you've made a good movie
you don't care about the missteps hmm
you can absolutely see them and point
them out I got a hundred missteps in
this movie I can point out but when
you've made an actual good movie those
missteps don't matter
they're just have so much less yeah it's
like eating a perfect hamburger but oh
there's like a small piece of the bun
missing it's like oh well still good
yeah like you know
that's definitely this movie when you
make a bad movie
that also has missteps and it may have
even less missteps in a movie like you
notice some more you notice it more you
know but but you get you get the the
most important stuff to get right they
get right the animation is gorgeous that
the world they travel to eventually is
unbelievable I'm gonna assume the 3ds
really good even though I guess I
haven't seen it yet in 3d but I really
want to the characters have really come
you know it it's not gonna like
necessarily coming full circle I feel
like they have really gone on a path and
it's a path that both kind of ends but
kind of continues to so so it's just
really really a good there and yeah it's
like the stuff they nailed it just nails
so good and so well I and I am so
grateful they did not give him a beard
for the whole movie I saw the trailers I
was just like oh no because it's like
he's got that beard and a man that I
said I'm like no I'm not gonna be able
to get it and like they saved that for
the very end and honestly was perfect
that ending was just flawless yes well I
don't know whether or not to feel sorry
for that dude or if I should just shut
the hell up because I'm with you every
time I hear that voice I'm like oh man
but I always warm up to it he if the
movie is good like Sorcerer's Apprentice
is that could be good but like with
these movies with man seeking woman
which is very very funny in he just he
does act very well and he is he does
have a good comedic timing and he can do
drama very well and so I feel like every
time I'm like oh that's a shame EF it
voice it's like he always works with it
and he always kind of makes it his own
and that's so a part of his identity now
and he's made it work now what it
doesn't work that's where it's really
really tough you know cuz it's like oh
man but when he when it does work with a
good director could write her and just
good acting it's like he really does
come into his own I think that really
really you get something surprisingly
very effect I always get used to it like
the first five minutes I'm like oh yeah
that's right and then by the end of it
I'm like know why I kick up yeah but
yeah the ending god I can't it's so long
since I've thought of a
perfect animated film ending but like
that that one I was just like just
perfect like I wouldn't change a thing I
thought and that's why I'm just like and
just just stop stop dude we have to
train your dragon' for it was that was
the perfect ending it felt right it
brought a smile to my face getting all
misty and and you know it's about
letting go and like just just just do it
yeah so um I think you get the general
idea there are a lot of little things
but I mean but that's the key they are
little things I think the big stuff that
you're supposed to care about it's
supposed to get really invested in
feeling like this is at the end of a
trilogy get the closure you get the
characters I've come a long way
animation is gorgeous it's still
creative as well as in these worlds just
look unbelievable and I like watching
them it's that's the stuff that matters
that it really really hits it right on
the ball and even though they had a
really shitty title the hidden world
that just is the most generic thing you
know we haven't seen we saw this one's a
hidden world we saw it's like we saw
this two weeks ago and as soon as I
pushed record I was about to say the
title like I have no idea I just said
How to Train Your Dragon three go back
you'll see just like oh yeah I mean that
but even that's kind of thing like
finding the hidden world it is not
really what the movies about the movie
is about it really it's about closer and
it does it very very well so um yeah
anything a hidden world as a metaphor
for all of our hearts definitely what
you go out on I got nothing I just I
really liked the movie and I'm not
saying it's perfect but the things that
it did right I thought it was way worth
it and I know like some people out there
just kind of like in the blog kind of
like yeah I'm sorry and I'm just like I
disagree I was kind of there to until we
got to the ending and I saw that
everything was doing and even though it
did not work I'm like okay no this this
is solid this is a good movie to go out
on
you know it but but it's okay to
acknowledge it does get other little
things
Rael it's okay now whatever you whatever
you think of it obviously but yeah I
mean it's definitely not for a mean of
Amar but when it hits I think it really
hits it strong so yeah that's about it
and we'll see you probably at at least I
will sit we'll see if we can do battle
angel we got to catch up on that because
we read that again I was out of town for
that so yeah hopefully they'll be the
next one and I'll see you next time late
you